اليه عسكريه مسطحه اسرائيليه الصنع في
خدمه الجيش الاوكراني بمنطقه خرسن هذه صور
نشرتها هيئه البث الاسرائيلي نقلا عن
صفحات الاوكرانيه ترصد انتشار الاسلحه وهي
لمصفحات من نوع امير من انتاج شركه
الاسرائيليه الخاصه غايه لم يذكر اي شيء
عن طريقه وصول هذه الاسلحه الى ساحه
المعارك باوكرانيا لكن اعين الاوكرانيين
تتجه من بدايه الحرب نحو سلاح اسرائيل اخر
اكثر من مره طلبت اوكرانيا اسرائيل بمدها
بهذا السلاح نظام الدفاع الجوي المعروف
بالقبه الحديديه يعرف الاوكرانيون ان
القبه الحديديه قادره على التصدي بفعاليه
لهذه الصواريخ الروسيه التي تبقى اكبر
تحدي تواجهه كياب في الحرب حاليا مارس
الرئيس الاوكراني
قويه على الحكومه الاسرائيليه لدفعها الى
تسليم بلاده قبه الحديديه في خطاب والجهل
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي في مارس الماضي تحدث
زنسكي الى النواب الاسرائيليين بلغه فيها
بعض التقريع وتسائل باستغراب عن رفض
اسرائيل تسليم بلاده لقبه الحديديه وذهب
الى حد تشبيه ما يحدث في بلاده بالهلوكست
لكن ذلك لم يكن كافيا لتغير الحكومه
الاسرائيليه موقفها خفيفه تل ابيب
الحسابات اكثر تعقيدا مما يطرحه دانت
اسرائيل حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا لكنها لم
تذهب ابعد من ذلك لكي لا تغضب موسكو
فالمقات ذات الاسرائيليه تشن غاراتها في
العنق السوريه على اهداف ايرانيه تحت اعين
انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسي
العامل الثاني الذي يحدد موقف اسرائيل
ووضع من بقي من اليهود في روسيا وضمان
تسهيلات بشانه هجرتهم الى اسرائيل اما
العامل الثالث فهو الاتفاق النووي
الايراني والدور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه روسيا
بهذا الشعب بهذه العوامل لم تغير حكومه يا
ايرلابيب موقفها حتى عندما قال زينسكي ان
ايران زودت روسيا بالف اي طائره مسيره من
نوع شاهد لكن بنيامين نتنياهو قال خلال
حمله الانتخابيه انه سينظر في امكانيه مد
اوكرانيا باسلحه لم يحدد ما هي هذه
الاسلحه هل هي القبه الحديديه ام اسلحه
اخرى
ونقلته اسره عن السفير الاوكراني في
اسرائيل قوله انه يعتقد ان تحولا
استراتيجيا يلوح في الافقي مع عوده نتنياه
الى السلطه الان ولا نتنياهو يستعد لتسلم
السلطه لا يعرف هل كان حديثه مجرد دعايه
انتخابيه ام انه جاد في تزويد اوكرانيا
بالسلاح والمغامره باثاره غضب موسكو التي
هددت بوضوح بانها ستعيد النظر في علاقتها
باسرائيل في هذه الحاله